I was at coffee earlier today and I
experienced actual racism in the in the
in what he called the public there were
these five white people at the coffee
place and then they were talking
Hollywood [ __ ] and you could tell
that it was not real and then there was
another table that wasn't with them that
was a black guy just kind of hanging out
and they were talking about movies loud
the guy was on the phone and he was like
yeah what I like to do is I like to
spend more to get more that's what I
like to do that's what he did so what
you knew immediately was that guy's full
of [ __ ] he was saying stuff like you
know what we we offered him 750 if we
got off from a little more than we got
off from a little more like and by the
way he was in [ __ ] like just a he
just he couldn't look less like a
producer hey some guy you're not making
a movie like that you can tell this guy
just wants to be heard and just wants to
be like powerful so he says to the guy
who's black that's not with them and he
says hey man what do you do and the guy
says I'm just a writer you know Hank
actor whatever and the guy says oh yeah
are you funny it's like you can tell
racism is is on the way uh racism just
got in the car and it's on though it was
like when you look at post mates and
it's like Oh preparing the order and
right when he said hey you funny that
was when it changed from preparing to
order and it says in rote and so the guy
says yeah I'm funny and he says yeah you
do chocolate sundaes at the Laugh
Factory it's obviously the urban night
at the Laugh Factory and it's on Sunday
so already the guy's like he's black you
do chocolate so he's like he can't do a
normal night of comedy hey all right
and the guy says yeah the guy actually
[ __ ] throws racism on its back and he
says yeah yeah yeah I do it I'm going
actually I'm doing it this week so then
he says hey do we have any it literally
says to his white
people there he says hey man do we have
any movies for black guys and that's
when I just looked over at him so I look
at this it's so this black guy cuz I cuz
the guy if the guy is like what the [ __ ]
then I'm gonna be like hey man yeah what
is yeah like if he if then if the white
guys like or well what I'll be like bro
you're being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but the black guy goes like this hell
yeah right one I'll do it so I'm like
okay well [ __ ] it you know as a white
guy who lives where I live you don't see
that that much you see subtle [ __ ] it
was so uncomfortable you know I was
surprised that the guy didn't say
anything I mean maybe he just deals with
it so much and [ __ ] like it's weird as a
white guy you don't really understand it
you don't really understand how much
that could possibly affect you all the
time over and over anyway people deal
with their if people have their own [ __ ]
to deal with it and that that maybe that
maybe that guy that guy today was just
like you know what I don't want to deal
with the [ __ ] racism [ __ ] at this
point
[ __ ] it maybe I could get some work out
of it I don't want to make it
uncomfortable I deal with this [ __ ] all
the time
[ __ ] it maybe maybe not maybe he was
maybe he didn't know IKEA had to have
known
you